if you were asked to think of the most
important wars in the 20th century you'd
likely think of the world wars Vietnam
or the wars of decolonization it's
unlikely that many people would think of
the three undeclared wars between
Iceland in the United Kingdom which
occurred between 1958 and 1976 these
were the cod Wars and were fought
between the Icelandic Coast Guard and
the Royal Navy and every time Iceland
won there's some nuance to this but to
put it mildly
this was embarrassing for Britain and
does raise the question how on earth did
Iceland defeat the United Kingdom three
times in a row so background British
fishermen have been using the waters
around Iceland for hundreds of years at
this point
as you know Britain's favourite dish
fish and chips required cod and lots of
it and so the British kept taking more
and more and more and more of it given
that Iceland's economy was based around
fishing this led to Icelandic incomes
decreasing by just under 20% and as such
the Icelandic government had to do
something as of the 1950s it was
internationally agreed that all nations
had exclusive use of the waters within
three miles of their coast in 1952
Iceland declared that they would
increase this to four miles and in 1958
they declared that they would further
increase it to twelve Britain decided to
ignore this because nobody else was
doing it and also Iceland was the little
nation with a population of about
170,000 people and so what were they
really going to do about it
well the Icelandic Coast Guard tried to
detain a British fishing trawler but had
to withdraw after the Royal Navy
intervened over the next two years both
sides fired warning shots at each other
but barring that there wasn't a great
deal of action in 1961 Britain climbed
down and agreed to recognise Iceland's
claim of twelve-mile was in return for
rights to fish there during certain
mumps the first Cod war was over but by
1971 Iceland was back to square one with
its fisheries in trouble again British
fishermen flocked to Iceland during the
mumps they were permitted to fish there
which led to depleted stocks and the
same problems as last time as such the
newly elected Icelandic government
declared that it held the exclusive
rights to all fish within 50 miles of
its coastline not only did this upset
Britain but also West Germany who also
had fishermen operating in the area and
Denmark Denmark was involved because it
saw the Icelandic demands as encroaching
on its waters around the Faroe Islands
Kew Cod war - international arbitration
ruled in favour of Britain Germany and
Denmark and Iceland then promptly
ignored it and started firing on British
trawlers and as a result it was time to
get the Royal Navy involved now
obviously this wasn't going to be
traditional naval war British ships
didn't to stop blowing up the Icelandic
Coast Guard instead they were ordered
only to respond to Icelandic ships
firing upon them but this didn't mean
that they couldn't do anything and it
wasn't long until British warships were
ramming Icelandic vessels and vice versa
which in turn led to several casualties
so Britain did have one major problem in
all of this naval e the two nations
weren't even comparable but Iceland had
an ace up its sleeve which was its
relationship to NATO and so does it
threatened to withdraw from NATO if
Britain didn't back down Britain didn't
wish to jeopardize the Alliance or more
specifically annoy the Americans and so
they agreed to recognize the Icelandic
demands this was done on the agreement
that British ships would be allowed to
return after two years and things were
finally sorted that is until the
agreement ran out and British ships
returned Cod war three you know the
drill by now Britain wanted to fish
Iceland said no one subsequently claimed
more exclusive fishing rights this time
200 miles Britain fished anyway the Navy
got involved ramming in 1976 Iceland
broke off international relations with
the UK and after a great deal of
pressure from the US Britain folded its
acknowledged Iceland's economic claims
that see him the two restored relation
soon after the cod wars were finally
over I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with the special
thanks to my patreon supporters who you
can see on screen here and with an extra
special thanks to James Bissonnette
David archaeologist party-boy Co Danny
Maloney Colin Castleman Rob otter house
are in the white Michael Reynolds H way
an emperor Chris wicker Gustav Swan
Gareth Turner spinning three plates
David Silverman Winston Cawood Maggie
packs Kowski Christian check' Anthony
Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and
Ike